Today I'm meeting the sons of Sheek
Nazim.
I am a Rever and I was taught how to
pray Salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from to Isa. If
you want to support someone like me in
learning salah, then sponsor 10 people
for just £100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said, "Charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate now.
Asalam alaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends we are in Medina. We are
going to be heading back to the UK
inshallah and probably celebrate Eid in
the sky. Alhamdulillah sisters uh before
we start brother sisters we have got a
limited amount left in if you guys are
still got you're still in Ramadan we are
ahead of you. We're talking from the
future actually. We're telling you if
you're still in Ramadan inshallah donate
brother sisters to this project sisters.
We have got set amount. We are trying to
fund 8,333 specific mats inshallah. We
only need £25,000 in guys. Every mat has
a a woodoo guide. It has a how to pray
salah even memorize surah fat in so
every time somebody does woodoo learn
salah learn surah faty. It they become a
saddaka machine for you brothers and
sisters. So £100 teaches 10 to 30 people
how to play salah. 10 pound teachers one
to three people inshallah. A,000 pound
teachers 100 to 300 people. Two and a
half thousand teaches 200 to 250 to 750
people. And if there's someone out there
who can give £5,000, it will teach 500
to 1,500 people. Let's get straight into
the video. Inshallah, the link is going
to be there to donate. Time is running
out inshallah and once we've raised it's
closed. This is a video that I saw of
sister Lily J. So she's someone who was
known for a chat GPT. Hey, you know,
chat GPT or whatever, etc.
Alhamdulillah. And now we saw her
obviously again she's spoke that she's
accepted Islam. Alhamdulillah. Um, now
she um is in hijab or she's partially in
hijab for a moment and she's heading to
a mosque. But this is run by an
individual called Sheh Nazim. Now Shikh
Nazim is somebody who a lot of scholars
I don't think it's run by Shikh Nazim.
It's by the replacement of Yeah. Yeah. I
mean is is his
group. Exactly. Now this um obviously
this individual um he's passed away now
um and a lot of scholars have deemed him
to be a deviant um do you know who's who
she who is his sheh no Abdah Distani
who's that from Distan that was his sheh
he learned from him and so we're going
to watch a video of her heading to Nazam
center and we just want to tell her just
to be careful certain things we're not
saying that these people are bad we're
not saying that we're just saying the
ideology behind that is very dangerous
so you're a new Muslim um just be
careful who you take what from inah. We
just want to show her vlog going there
and let's see what we can take from
inshallah and talk about this movement
and how dangerous they could be. Today
I'm meeting the sons of Sheek Nazim who
had over 40 million students and now his
sons have taken over his legacy. People
from all around the world come to learn
about Islam. It's like I've stepped in a
time machine back 1400 years. They are
trying to live like the Sahaba did. It's
like a fullon community here where
everyone helps out wherever they can. So
this lady was from Kazakhstan and was
making a traditional noodle dish from
her hometown. They were doing some old
style carpentry. So traditional and so
cool. Brother, who controls all this?
They work together as a unit. They like
to share everything. They like to share
the food and anybody love to come and
eat. So nobody control it. It's
controlled by Allah. It's so cute.
Everyone brings a dish to share. This
community is so multicultural. It's
amazing to see. Kazakistan, UK, Turkey,
Germany, France, Brazil, Chile, Egypt.
It's like one big family. I was honored
to be invited by one of the sons, Sheek
Bahadin, to his place for if aar and
meet his beautiful family. Now it's time
to break fast. We made a prayer showing
gratitude to God for the meal we are
about to eat. For our we have our tea
and uh dates then after we pray then we
have our dinner. We break fast with
dates and water like the prophet did.
You are promoting the sincerity. When
you are sincere you will have a lot of
enemy. Don't think I'm sincere and I'm
free. No. Then the work will start and
the biggest enemy for you will be your
ego. Very true. Now we're going to pray.
Prayer is finished. Time to eat. The
food looks absolutely amazing.
[Music]
There were noodles, sweet and sour soup,
chicken, yra, dolma, beef, spring rolls,
salad soups. Oh, so good.
We had some dessert and tea and then we
had a chat with Shik Bahad to learn more
and discuss Islam. I follow you. I
appreciate what you do. It was like you
have touch of the heart of the people.
Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
Then it was time for Tawi prayer and I
did 20 raats. It was a beautiful way to
spend the 27th night of Ramadan.
Hopefully it was Leila
Dada. And this is Sheekch Memed, the son
of Sheekch Nazim, who was his chosen
successor. He was incredibly kind. He
gave me some words of encouragement and
a meaningful gift which they only give
out once a year on Leila Tada. I am so
honored.
So obviously now as she's a new reaver,
she might watch this video. It might be
a bit like, oh my gosh, like what's
going on? Um, the reason we're doing
this
video and also I did get in contact with
sister Ly J to send her a mat for
herself to learn how to pray. She
doesn't know how to pray. It is still
there. We sent it for free. salah
plus.com. She can order it herself. It's
absolutely for free. And we actually
teaching another public figure which is
the Japanese sisters who came to Islam.
Our head of sisters salah team is
teaching her how to pray salah in
sending a mat to her. We spoke to her.
So it's there for anybody to use. But um
it's very important as a new Muslim
yourself when you come to understand
what is the concept of Islam. And when
the race concept of Islam, the one first
thing is tohed. Now what are the major
things that Sheh Nazim he was known as a
sheh and Nazim came up with that is very
dangerous. A she who does not know
Quran, he does not know hadith. I have
never heard him or anybody that follow
followed the knows about him to have
said you know you spoke about let's
let's kind of dissect this if someone
says that there are others with Allah
like they call them portable
that's what they call it's like a saint
it's like a saint Okay. And this are
with and they look at the
preserved tablet.
Yeah. Is that is that or no? I find that
problematic. I find that very
problematic. What about you do not have
to pray to Allah directly but you have
to pray to Allah through you have to or
you can. You have to. No that's yeah I
mean both of them you can is problematic
let alone you have to. You have to. So
that's like association.
Don't pray to Allah directly but you
pray to him through from this that they
call the saints that they call and that
now this is one you want to know the
worst one look we talk about is part of
yes okay will you
tell a pope to pray for you
no why would ask a pope to pray for he
needs to pray for himself he's doing
shik he needs he needs to ask guidance
for I can show you evidence evidence
Yeah. From
okay from him saying to Pope Benedict
the 16th do dua for me.
Okay. Yeah. That's No, I want your
reaction on this. No, I mean I mean it's
for me it's like me going to a Hindu and
saying can you go to your false deities
and pray for me? Well well it's in fact
it's like you're approving that. It's
it's there. It's there. What is it like?
It's there for everyone to see Ali
brother. Well, to me that's very
problematic and this is the reason why
we're just saying to new Muslims, this
is for Lily J, but other Muslims, new
Muslims to be careful who you take from.
It's very very important guys because
look where she went what they're doing
is in the sense we're feeding people
coming. We don't have we're not denying
this. We're not saying they're bad
people. We're saying the ideology the
Hindus do the same thing. The Hindus
they feed people they do that you know
all of that. Does that mean that their
creed is correct? No. This is where
women the the the Christians in their
churches so many of them do really great
works. They take the migrants, they take
the the addicted people that are
addicted, the poor and that and they
give them food and that does that mean
that their creed is correct? No, it's
not. So, Subhan Allah, it's not about
look we love for the sake of Allah and
we dislike for the sake of Allah. You
know, we don't dislike people. This is
very important to show. Yes. We dislike
the action. We dislike the action of
people. Once them people leave that
action, they become our beloved
brothers. Exactly. So people get this.
Oh, Muslims do hate. Muslims do hate.
No, we don't hate. We hate kufur. We
hate shaitan. We hate evil deeds. This
is what we hate. But you as a person, we
don't hate you. Exactly. One thing I
would say to Jay is because you ask GPT
about Quran and you say for example, can
is Jesus a god? and the charge you to
answer and you get really satisfied.
Yeah, of course. Because you already
believe in your fra which is that Jesus
cannot God can Jesus cannot meet God. A
man cannot go. What you need to
understand here is that there's there's
association happening because Islam is
one worship of God alone. So if you were
told no uh Lily, you have to go through
a saint to go to God or ask through a
saint, you will say, what's the
difference between this and
Christianity? I accept I accepted.
Catholicism. Yeah. Catholicism is like
that's why I'm saying Lady Jay, please
sister be careful. I messaged you on uh
in on Instagram about the prayer mass as
well. Alhamdulillah. It's still there
and you don't need to get go through me.
You can go to salah plus.com. Our sister
can get in contact with you if you want
to learn how to pray salah. But what
we're saying is be very careful because
you are obviously vulnerable in the
sense where you're a new Muslim and
these things can be make you, you know,
cuz it's an emotional thing where you
like, oh, they're doing so much good. We
don't deny that. We're saying be careful
because you don't want to end up doing
an action that makes you fall into
something that's a major sin. Yeah. Was
at the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam he was so known of his good
character and generosity. Yeah. That he
became a proverb a saying in generosity.
You
say more generous than he he reached the
epitm of generosity. You know what he
used? He would if someone comes he would
slaughter a horse for them. his ser his
slaves if they would find if they would
bring him someone as a guest he would
freed him for the sake because they
that's how how and look how what good he
did and that and then
once she asked the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam about if he is he said
to her he has never mentioned Allah in
his life so how really
how would he how would he come to uh to
be exactly as maybe he's doing that
because one of the first it was pretty
Islamic but I'm I'm still saying I'm
still saying Allah he's not going to
forgive him because he used to feed and
that we have one thing doing good deeds
is one thing but there is if you if you
do if you oppress the duty with Allah
which is if you commit it doesn't matter
how many
We came to their deeds and we made it
like dust. Yes. Yes. Exactly. So it's
like for example if I was good to
everybody uh you know if Jay you're
watching this if I was good to everyone
else but I was going home and punching
my mom in the face. Would you say would
you say I'm a good person or a bad
person?
So if I don't give the rights of Allah
it doesn't matter what good I'm doing to
anyone else. That's why it's important
JJ when you're doing chap GPT and it
talks about Allah his wonders his
rights. This falls under that inshallah.
So it's just a little thing for us to be
careful and not just you. It's just to
anyone that's be careful. Can I say
something? A great misguidance. Can I
say something more? He had a foul mouth.
Look, the man is dead and I don't want
to speak about it, but we're just saying
the things that are known. Yeah, you
need We're not lying about the man. I'm
not going to go even into lots of other
things that he used to do. I'm not going
to go into them. Yeah, but a man like
him in his stance and that he was
foulmouthed especially to the Salafies
who whom he calls Wahhabies. You
understand anybody that is
not on his way and that he is a man that
love to live in London and Paris and and
so you know what I
mean? Let alone the free mixing let
alone other other things. I'm not gonna
go into the man is dead. Yeah. He is
with Allah and Allah will judge him
according to his deeds. Exactly. Yeah.
Exactly. So, we're not gonna go. But can
you imagine being in that status and
have a foul mouth
says obscinities and stuff like that
speaking from the waist below. I mean,
it doesn't be anyone. But brothers and
sisters, that's all we want to say.
Inshallah. Share this with sister Lily
J. And like I said before guys, if
there's anyone out there who doesn't
know how to pray salah, who wants to
learn, you can order this guide to
pray.com guys. We'll send that for free.
And if you can donate guys, we do want
to hit our target today. Inshallah, it's
we are still looking for one person to
donate £10,000 that will teach 1,000 to
3,000 people to learn salah. Till next
time.